whether it's music sports or film if
there's something people love you can
count on fans crossing the line into
full-blown crazy and comic book fans are
no exception especially since Marvel
movies began dominating at the box
office
so grab your Mii or Nia and hold on
tight because here's a look a few Marvel
fans who took things too far it ain't
easy being green in 2012 a 35 year old
brazilian man named paulo one week de
santos painted himself green and dressed
as a whole for a running event
unfortunately the paint turned out to be
super heavy-duty stuff used on ballistic
missiles and nuclear submarines and what
do you know it wouldn't wash off even
after 20 buffs Santos remained as green
as the Hulk it eventually took a crowd
of friends 24 hours of scrubbing to
finally get the green paint out of
Santos his skin
no wonder the Hulk is always angry the
best there is at what he does in October
2017 during an Australian comic
convention a 28 year old man dressed as
Wolverine was arrested for allegedly
playing his part a little too well
around 2:00 a.m. after being kicked out
of a pub on Sydney's King Street The
Wolverine fan allegedly attacked two men
injuring one and knocking the other
unconscious both victims were brought to
the hospital while the man dressed as
Wolverine was arrested it was not
revealed if the dispute began over an
underground cage match or of either of
the alleged victims and called the
wannabe Wolverine a dirty mutti before
hostilities broke our spider-man hero or
menace what's better than one spider-man
well the answer is lots of Spider Men
right earlier today tragedy striking the
new musical spider-man - too many Spider
Men the show billed as the most flying
spider-man ever assembled on one stage
well if j jonah jameson were real the
crimes allegedly perpetrated by people
dressed as spider-man would have made
him feel pretty vindicated for instance
a robber dressed as spider-man
allegedly held up at HSBC Bank in the
Bronx in April of 2017 as part of a
Spidey crime spree involving a number of
attempted thefts and that's not the
first time from New York City to st.
Cloud Florida spider-man seems to be the
superhero costume of choice for many
would-be criminals but there are heroic
spider-man as well such as the
Birmingham England Spidey who Don the
sooo to feed the homeless and then
there's Kevin Gordon Pryor who
reportedly broke up a brawl between
around 30 or 40 people in England while
dressed a spy day and it wasn't the
first time he made headlines for saving
the day a Spider Man either hey with no
power comes great responsibility a king
of pop art at the 2009 San Diego Comic
Con a surely after Michael Jackson's
death Stanley opened up about the king
of pops interest in Marvel and Spider
Man Lee claimed he and Jackson had sat
down once to discuss the possibility of
pooling their resources to by Marvel
Comics with at least part of Jackson's
incentive being to get control over film
portrayals of spider-man Lee said I'm
not sure whether he just wanted to
produce it or wanted to play the role
our conversation never got that far
along Jackson playing Spidey may sound
far-fetched but it apparently wasn't the
only superhero he had his eye on as
x-men screenwriter David Hayter revealed
in 2017 that michael jackson wanted the
film role of x-men founder Professor X
seeing red when you think of the most
extreme hardcore fans and the subjects
of their obsession you probably wouldn't
choose Captain America bad guy the red
skull as the most obvious subject of
such intense passion but Venezuela's
Henry Rodriguez has taken fan obsession
to a whole new level even undergoing
facial reconstruction to look more like
the arch villain his transformation
includes facial and eye tattoos cutting
off his nose and subdermal implants in
his face and brow and did we mention he
cut off his nose unfortunately all of
those tattoos and face altering
surgeries left Rodriguez looking less
like the Red Skull and more like a Rex
from Mass Effect Shepherd shepherd
shepherd Rex Shepherd shepherd thanks
for watching take the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]